und der neue ard sprecher tino group
aller ist uns jetzt aus braunschweig
zugeschaltet guten tag herr gruppe guten
tag herr kohl hallo opa der flügel der
afg ist laut verfassungsschutz ein prüf
fall und werde immer extremistischer und
der führende kopf des flügels blöcke
empfiehlt sie als guten mann ist ihre
wahl ein beleg dafür dass der radikale
flügel in der spitze angekommen ist nein
wir haben mehrere strömungen unserer
partei dazu gehört auch der flügel
ähnlich wie ich die werte union in der
cdu hat oder der seeheimer kreis in der
spd
wenn man hier gewählt werden möchte und
das hat auch dieser bundesparteitag
gezeigt was man lagerübergreifend
position vertreten können das tue ich
ich wirke integrierend und ich freue
mich trotzdem auf diese zusammenarbeit
mit teilen der partei aus allen lagern
also auch mit dem flügel in ihrer rede
gestern auf dem parteitag haben sie sich
gegen drastische sprache ausgesprochen
sie selbst sind aber durchaus schon
durch radikale wortwahl aufgefallen sie
haben beispielsweise einmal von
umvolkung gesprochene begriff der im
verfassungsschutzbericht steht und der
der nazi sprache entlehnt ist das heißt
sie distanzieren sich der gerade von
ihrer eigenen sprache also von sich
selbst ich habe nicht in persona non
grata per umvolkung gesprochen natürlich
ganz klar dementieren
wenngleich ich natürlich bei bürger
spricht und auch diese begrifflichkeiten
zu hören bekomme also darauf in diesem
fall bei ihm noch reagieren
also sie haben davon gesprochen ja aber
ich halte die umvolkung ich halte den
begriff umvolkung nicht für rechtsextrem
oder diese form halte ich nicht für
rechtsextreme aber der
verfassungsschutzbericht sagt das ist
sprache der nationalsozialisten
wir wissen alle dass der
verfassungsschutz in deutschland
politisch agiert um die größte
oppositionspartei zu schädigen und zu
diffamieren
also es ist ja auch historisch ein
absolut verankerter begriff in der
nationalsozialistischen völkischen
sprache ja also wie gesagt der
verfassungsschutz agiert in diesem land
gegen die größte oppositionspartei
politisch das will ich ganz klar
unterstreichen und ich weiß nicht was
hinauskommen hinaus kommen wollen weil
ihnen das nicht weil das nicht klar was
das für ein begriff ist oder haben sie
ihn bewusst gesetzt ich habe ich nicht
bewusst gesetzt wo es auch wenig
interpretationsspielraum geben kann ist
ein zweites beispiel ich möchte ihnen
einen auszug vorspielen aus einer
veranstaltung mit ihnen im märz 2018 wo
sich ein teilnehmer drastisch über die
vermeintlichen folgen von migration
äußert anderes als film
er will es danach uns deutschen sondern
nur eingeschränkt sind wir deutschen
wenn es mal ganz was 45
die jungs dann geändert in nürnberg das
müsste man nochmal ansprechen problem
wieder zum anfang ich wir erinnern uns
wo wir auch belacht oderbruch peggy
double 8 wurde wo wir vor einer
islamisierung des abendlandes sprachen
ja und wir sehen ja mittlerweile das ist
realität und ich finde da gebe ich ihnen
zum teil recht in einem atemberaubenden
tempo
der kubaner wenn hier von jungs
gesprochen wird die am galgen in
nürnberg beendet sind dann geht es ja um
verurteilte kriegsverbrecher der
nürnberger prozesse also der
verherrlichung von nationalsozialismus
widersprechen sie da nicht mit allen
mitteln verstehe ich das richtig
ja sie sagen mitteln ich habe ich habe
dem sehr wohl widersprochen
wie sieht das jetzt interpretieren für
ihre auslegung ist ihre natürlich ihre
einzige sache aber ich möchte die sache
das was der herr da eben in der
veranstaltung gesagt hat war doch ganz
klar was war das klar dass er die
nationalsozialisten da als die
kriegsverbrecher als jungs bezeichnet
und sie haben gesagt ja ich gebe ihnen
zum teil recht das habe ich nicht getan
dass ich eben auf diesem punkt recht
gegeben habe das interpretieren sie
völlig falsch habe ich ihnen ja gerade
gesagt
das sagt dehoga schön der mit
unterstützung des nationalen flügels
gestern zum neuen fdp bundesspitze wählt
wurde
danke ihnen nach braunschweig